Deadpool was a film that was slightly
inconsistent for me whilst I loved the
gags sick body horror and over-the-top
gore
story-wise it felt a bit by the numbers
obviously I'm aware that origins stories
are often used primarily as set up for
what's to come
and that they shouldn't be judged
harshly for creating a world and story
beans for our protagonists to use in
future in fact pretty much every first
film in the franchise is probably my
least favorite across the board whether
it's Batman Begins
Spider Man Man of Steel and many more
they all feel pretty by the numbers and
it's rare that I choose them over their
counterpart films and their respective
franchises so naturally when Deadpool 2
got announced I was excited to see
whether it could fix the failings of the
first film after leaving the theater I
definitely felt it achieved its goal of
besting Deadpool and overall I had a fun
ride with it
however after doing research on the
movie I was shocked to learn that quite
a lot being cut from its runtime when an
extended edition titled the super duper
cut was announced I became intrigued as
to what could be included and whether it
would elevate the film in the past
extended cut often enhanced films for me
and in the case of Batman V Superman
even changed it from an incoherent mess
to one of my favorite comic book films
of all time
Deadpool twos extended cut may not
change a negative opinion into a
positive one but what it does do is that
it provides a plethora of new jokes gags
and even a deleted post-credit scene
that will have you leaving the film with
a huge grin on your face metaphorically
I described Deadpool to as a stand-up
comedy set that has been edited for
video it's tighter
has less awkward laughs and pauses and
feels like what the comedian would
present if they had the perfect
night in contrast Deadpool 2 is a longer
set with some jokes that don't hit
completely but it also feels like the
complete patient of the film now if
you're watching this you probably want
to know should I go out of my way to
check out the super duper car if I
already own the theatrical version
personally I don't think so whilst there
is over 14 minutes of extra footage some
of it feels like needless padding that
was cut from the movie for good reason
we get two scenes that follow Russell as
he's brought to the orphanage and
another that sees him tortured by the
headmaster both scenes flesh out subtext
that was mentioned in the original cut
but are completely unnecessary to the
overall plot these scenes were hinted at
in the original cut and viewers were
left to draw their own conclusions as to
his troubled past which i think works
slightly better than the confirmation
that we get here you aren't really
missing much by not picking it up unless
of course you want to see the Hitler
baby post-credit scene which is present
here after being highly reported as
being too offensive for audience goers
to see in cinemas it definitely is the
perfect way to end the film and had me
smiling from here to here as the disc
menu came back up so it's a rather so-so
endorsement from me I picked up the 4k
edition of the film and was blown away
by just how detailed that cool suit was
as well as how grim and gritty the
prison scene looked it's a beautiful
film that provides more of the same for
hardcore fans but whether you should
pick it up or not depends on your
tolerance for the character and if you
weren't one round by the theatrical
release and you probably won't be here I
must admit though I had a lot of fun
with Deadpool - super duper car and it
definitely is the only way that I will
be watching the film from now on
however it's not worth the double-dip
and those who already own the original
version will have more than enough to
keep them occupied until we find out
exactly what Disney are going to do
franchisee so in my eyes Deadpool 2 gets
an 8.5 out of 10 so what did you think
of Deadpool - super duper car do you
prefer it over the original and which
film do you think is the best in the
franchise comment below and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and subscribe to my channel I create
content like this weekly and they'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film make sure
you check out my video which breaks down
the infamous deleted post-credit scene
at the end of this one and thanks again
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you